and so people came in they split the
lens up even more they started selling
more and that's how you know what was
once a protected indigenous community
ends up no longer being that way and
ends up being an urban center because of
its proximity to work and to to
resources that people need to survive by
the time I'm in there doing my research
in the 1990s and and I took a team of
graduate student researchers in there
and we tested the cones and we tested
but you're looking at 60 65 percent lead
in these glazes and you're looking at
kilns that only reach four hundred four
hundred and sixty degrees Celsius which
means they're not sealing in that led in
the way in which they did and so the
community is now suffering from massive
health repercussions from lead poisoning
which is how I ended up getting into
nutrition because once LED is in your
body really there's nothing we can do
about it but it's more than just the
cooking because women's identity is
ceramic production it's what gave them
political and economic autonomy yeah it
was the reason for the first time that
women became independent economic
earners so now I'm the one going to the
women and saying you're ceramic is
harming you and it's harming your
children no no it is not we've been
making this ceramic for you know
hundreds of years kind of thing but now
you ask women to give up the very thing
that gave them that empowerment and that
defines them as as viable people that
that community is known for its ceramic
if they stop producing ceramic they're
not that community anymore there's
something else they're an urban
anonymous entity so the way in which
their identity is tied to it the way in
which women have to make decisions about
what do i do do I give up this ability
to be autonomous plus
happening all around the world all
around the world yes because cottage
craft is helping small marginalized
populations survive so that the states
don't have to invest in wow there's so
much beauty actually there's so much
trauma but there's so much beauty and I
think the greatest beauty is looking
into the eyes of a stranger and
receiving a smile that goes back to yeah
well one someone's opinion may
contradict yours where's my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we in what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on we are on site
at the American Anthropological
Association Annual Meeting in Vancouver
British Columbia in Canada this is our
second partnership with them we are now
gonna be speaking with dr. Ramona Perez
hi it's very nice to be here thank you
for inviting me we're so grateful to
have you on the program I'm so pumped
for our getting me pumped yeah yeah I
think I think it's that after gets a
thank you yeah yeah yeah Ramona was just
elected the president-elect / vice
president in 2019 and 2021 and she's
gonna assume the office of president of
the American Anthropological Association
in 2021
right and I still run me all the way to
2023 yeah yeah yeah and I love the you
know the foresight with how you have
this - you're kind of like incubation
yeah and then I love that and you have
an exit period as well of staying with
it from 2023 until 2020 no after 2023
you basically step down but what
inevitably happens is they capture you
and ask you to take on some kind of task
force or some kind of working group
because you've got all this vast
knowledge right yes yes so it's been a
long time since I've seen a triple-a
president actually roll off and get to
have there
back yeah well your this is such a cool
and multidisciplinary field of ethology
so you gain so much knowledge about the
world by being deeply involved in this
organization
Ramona's also professor of anthropology
and director of the Center for Latin
American Studies at San Diego State
University
among some myriad of other credentials
Ramona I really want to start with the
big questions that we love asking on the
show are we really all one you know um I
wish there was a single answer for that
are we all one we are one human species
we are one people that we take many
different forms and we respond and react
and create different cultural reactions
to our environments but ultimately yeah
we are we are one human entity we're all
the same and also in combination with
all of the other millions of species on
the planet all evolving whether you call
it a Big Bang or whether you call it God
or creation or source or all that is or
whatever word you want to use to
describe it it all comes from one yeah
now you're talking to anthropologists
right you're talking anthropologists who
believe in the evolutionary process and
the understanding of there was something
out there that just brought us forward
and we have evolved since then into the
multiple ways in which life exists on
this planet yes yes would you say that
the most upstream issue that we face is
the feelings of separation the feelings
the lack of interconnectedness and
that's causing the downstream issues
you know it's um again I'm not going to
give you a super straightforward answer
on that because for as long as we can
tell human beings have understood a
difference animals understand difference
and we also understand that survival is
a key part of who we are and so
territory tends to come into play and
being able to protect and being able to
create ways in which we survive so a
lack of interconnectedness I think we
are more connected at this moment in
global history than we ever have been in
terms of recognizing the
interconnectedness now whether or not we
choose to accept that interconnectedness
as positive it's something very
different but I think some of these
downstream issues and I think what I'm
interpreting from your question about
downstream issues are some of the
problems that we're having and caring
for each other in respecting each other
and in honoring the many ways in which
we all need to express ourselves and
live it's not just survival it's about a
quality of life and we're having a
really hard time maintaining that kind
of honor and respect for the multiple
ways in which human beings can create a
positive quality of life for themselves
that I think is no different than it
might have been at any other time in
terms of saying how is this impacting me
and how is this impacting me in terms of
my ability to survive what's different
is what we decide we need to survive and
we don't need all the things that were
laying claim to and that have come to
have great importance to us whether that
is a socioeconomic status that we're
trying to protect and we believe we're
being invaded by somebody who might come
along and somehow jeopardize that or the
way in which we want our children and
our families to think and believe at
worship and and exist we are
not honoring the multiple ways in which
that could happen because we feel
threatened it's most of the hate and the
bigotry I would personally say derives
from a sense of fear of loss a fear that
somehow or another I can't maintain a
positive way of life or I can't reach
that goal that I see out there
that will give me that positive life
because something's in my way when you
brought forth this recognition that we
are more interconnected now and there
was this sort of there was a connection
between maybe the head or the brain of
like this these this interconnectedness
and maybe that in itself has some of
those root issues of being so deeply in
our own heads all the time where in our
hearts lies the real feeling of complete
interconnectedness and not only with
other humans but every inhale I take is
phytoplankton and trees breathing out
every bite of an apple I take as the Sun
and soil powering that home if children
aren't passed along that initial first
principled wisdom of reality then things
downstream there's issues that happen
okay I'm gonna go along with that okay
okay
okay cuz okay cool um he's just like so
I'm listening to you and I'm
appreciating and I'm totally engaged
with it at the same time I'm recognizing
that the very technology that we're
employing right now has a negative
impact on the globe the the way in which
we have taken mineral resources and
turned them into transformers that allow
us to sit here and
have this conversation and then project
it out does not have a positive impact
on the future of the GLIP
environmentally sustainability as
sustainably what it does do is that
further links us in this
interconnectedness that you're talking
about and gives us the opportunity to
share maybe the way in which we're
thinking about something that might help
somebody else take them were broader
take a more broad or a deeper look at
something that they might be resisting
or or fighting against so it has a
positive but it has an environmentally
negative impact too and those are the
kinds of you know issues that we
constantly have to weigh what is the
value of that and how is that going to
impact us and I'm not sure we can always
make straightforward decisions about
that yeah when we take the
interconnected feelings of what is at
the core of indigeneity and then we look
at modernity and we look at the light
pollution we look at the exchanging a
sheet of paper for the Apple we look at
the technological devices and driving
excellence in many ways and driving
disconnection and others the
embedding of many of the first principle
values of indigeneity into the future of
where modernity goes seems to be one of
the most critical things to be aware of
so tell me what you mean by intogen
anity this is a very good question yeah
yeah and I think what I was referencing
earlier about the understanding of the
interconnectedness through the breaths
of air and through the bites of food and
through inclusive fitness there's
another big one so you're referring back
to a time and a people and a moment that
exists now as well as it did in the past
about their understanding and
appreciation that the whole that the
that a physical environment gives us
life and that for everything that we
take from the physical environment we
sometime we somehow or another have to
give it back and if we do that right it
will be a positive cycle of life but
that got interrupted right because it's
no longer about a way in which we can
positively give back to the earth
without somehow or another advancing the
way in which we see ourselves living so
I think that's kind of what you're
asking you know where you're you're
you're going with this I mean yes we we
we all need to really understand what
our footprint is as everybody likes to
refer to it you know just what kind of
impact are we making on the earth every
day with every decision that we make but
we also don't live lives that are so
intimately bound to our immediate
environment that we understand the
repercussions of that we don't live next
to the landfill well many of us don't
live next to the ant landfill others
live their lives off the landfill it is
from our waste that they get life which
is a
a trauma in and of itself for many of us
that have worked alongside men women and
children who forged through vast dumps
in order to eke out a living yeah Ramona
I'm wondering overall is what we're
talking about right now and the sheer
complexity of the evolution of life from
its origins until this point of 8
billion human civilization plus a
hundred million species that have been
here and you know 10 million that are
here now with us all figuring out how to
behave as a biosphere and progress
moving forward and mostly humans
figuring out how to handle it would you
say that this in itself the complexity
of this experience that we're all a part
of this reality would you say that that
is the purpose of it being made of what
being made of this reality being made
was for us to all experience the beauty
and complexity of what we're all going
through right now I have no idea I have
no idea how to determine whether or not
there is something up there as you're
saying that somehow or another guided us
to this point in order for us to learn
from it and somehow or another begin to
undo can't answer that question I don't
think any of us come you know that's
something that we each have to try and
wrestle with inside ourselves but we
have to slow down long enough to do that
yes we have to slow down and really ask
those questions and there aren't a whole
lot of people that are willing to make
to ask those questions and then to make
the decisions that might go along with
that if they recognize that the many
things that we do have this kind of
negative impact but you did it you also
didn't talk about artificial
intelligence in the way in which
artificial intelligence has begun to
make decisions for us this is the first
time at the conference that someone else
has brought it up before me so that's
the artificial intelligence yeah I've
been trying
move some of the anthropology's that
we've had on the program and outside
just to give us their thoughts on
artificial intelligence automation
robotics biotech neuro tech the future
of augmenting humans the future of work
as what humans can do that's better than
artificial intelligence is slowly and
slowly that area is closing or making
artificial general intelligence as a
super intelligences are we the
biological bootloader for building that
as the next step how do you feel about
that there are so many ethical and and
future sub kind of questions that you're
asking me right now and I can't answer
all of them artificial intelligence is
here artificial intelligence has been
here for quite some time we've
recognized the import and the power that
it would have back you know from the
original sci-fi movies right from the
1950s and 60s I think human beings have
been wrestling with how far are we going
to let this go and where are we going to
take it and and should we have a
respectable fear for it but there is no
denying that it's a significant part of
every one of our lives and let's face it
you know artificial intelligence and
that makes our lives easier makes it
super simple for us to simply accept it
passively so we are complicit in the
growth of artificial intelligence with
every smartphone that we have with every
laptop we have with with the desire to
be able to control our lights and our
thermostat and everything else from a
phone you are talking about ways in
which we are asking nonhumans to do
things that have always had a human
intervention in them now we just get to
go like that
and it gets done for us you bring up
this great point of it the advance of
artificial intelligence making it more
so that
we have less involvement in some of the
things that end up coming up in our
lives used to be we had a lot of say and
now so with much of what we do we no
longer necessarily get us a lots is
driven by algorithms and the interests
of governments and large corporations
and billionaires and we don't
necessarily know if you made a hierarchy
of people by wealth just a very classic
way that people look at a hierarchy we
don't know how many of the 1500
billionaires on the planet have ever
felt feelings of interconnectedness or
unconditional love no idea and if you
make a hierarchy based on spiritual
enlightenment and you put the Dalai Lama
and other people at the top
why wouldn't we focus on what they are
preaching why don't we focus on building
our future civilization based on that
style of a hierarchy I would much rather
have that and I hope thing messages like
that can resonate with other people I
have many other questions yet there's
but you haven't given me a glass of wine
so I'm not gonna engage a kind of sit
back and be able to provoke you a little
bit more in terms of what you're asking
we're so obsessed with the big-picture
questions and it's even great to hit the
ball back a little bit on on them but on
in terms of like more concrete research
on your end and what's actually led you
here this these topics are so vast a
stat culture and education global health
women's studies transnational Mexican
and Central American migrant youth
ethnic marginalization political economy
of tourism in Oaxaca
well Hakka Hakka Oaxaca
immigration expert witness testimony
child detention where can you take us
from this like mackerel I know listen
though you know every day I get up and I
go who am i today
listen you know it's it's one of these
things that I think really gets at what
we do in in anthropology and that's a
beautiful thing about this discipline
and I'm sure you've heard this over and
over again it there isn't a question
that's off-limits from us
which makes it fascinating discipline to
be able to dive into because we approach
it from so many different angles right
we really try to understand how the
biological body play into the kinds of
things that are happening over here and
you know when we communicate how is this
communication really capturing or not
capturing what our intended meaning is
and are we conveying and is it being
received and in in the way in which we
imagine you know all the way down to how
do we make sense out of our world and
create cultural processes and practices
that allow us to interact yeah so you
know having these kind of broad research
topics are I think a result of the way
in which our minds never stop running in
some of us are driven some of us are
driven by from by outside questions that
come to us and others others of us are
driven by the questions that the very
people that were working with the
communities that we're working with are
asking us so I think we do some of us do
a little bit of both and that's
certainly what you know happened with me
this is my second career so I'm an ex
corporate banker who gave it all up and
just decided you know I said 29 years
old you know what I don't I don't want
to be a corporate banker I don't I don't
want to do this anymore so I'm gonna go
put a backpack on and I'm gonna go to
college so going through that in
deciding anthropology was the discipline
that was going to allow me to have that
next life in that next world was really
important I come from a very traditional
family very traditional Mexican family
my father's Mexican
my mother's united states in he ended up
having this propensity for languages so
he spoke 13 languages so I didn't really
grow up in the USA oh why yes he was
absolutely a polyglot which meant he was
part of the Intelligence Service which
means that I was six months old when I
left the US and I was basically an
adolescent when we came back so I grew
up in other parts of the world I grew up
in Germany and Turkey and Spain and yeah
and then I come back into the US and I'm
still being rate I'd still have this
very traditional Mexican background and
say my father wouldn't let me go to
college so right right so this is part
of my women's studies this is where you
see me getting into research on gender
and gender roles and how that plays out
and so I I basically accomplished my my
role I was a senior vice president for
an American Express subsidiary when I
quit and decided to go to school for the
first time at 29 and get my
undergraduate degree and and all the way
up through my doctorate but my question
that that drove me to anthropology is so
what is it about Mexican culture in
particular that maintains these very
structured gender roles even though
we're not in the same environments that
we were when our parents grew up why do
they continue to have these very strict
gender roles you know why couldn't I go
to college why was it so important to
him that I get married at 19 you know
what what what was it about this so you
know anthropology really allowed me to
think about that from all kinds of
different perspectives and so that's
what I actually originally sought out to
understand and I started in Oaxaca in
the 1990s because migration was fairly
recent in terms of it having a big
impact on that state so that would mean
that mothers and fathers are having to
make decisions that my parents were
making when I was younger so I could go
and really watch that unfold I could be
a part of it and engage with women as
they are trying to make a decision how
am I going to raise my daughter how am I
going to raise my
son because my world is changing I'm not
just living off the land I'm no longer
bound only to agriculture we've started
migrating tourism is coming in and so
that's that's how I started out you know
my doctoral research was originally
looking at the impact of the
commodification of women's bodies
through tourism when the Oaxacan state
decided that it was women's craft that
was going to take them into the next
tourist market they selected various
communities where craft was driven by
women and they created an entire program
around that well I got to be in a
ceramic producing community eight
kilometres outside the capital city of
Oaxaca City and work inside a community
just as it was opening up there were the
the artisans market was built and
installed in that community in 1993 I
moved there in 1994 and then I moved
there for my long-term research in 1995
and did about 18 months of field
research there
I still work in that community I'm on my
fourth generation of women understanding
that impact of how they're negotiating
across time and across the integration
of a once dominant rural community into
a community now it was 5200 people
including all the people in the small
ranches on the outside today that same
community is almost 60,000 people whoa
yeah yeah 1995 it was a 5200 people
in 2019 and at the 2020 census will tell
us even more
we're probably closer to 60,000 it has
to do with a whole lot of things but it
has to do with the fact that they are
eight kilometres outside the capital
city and as rural to urban migration
occurs they were impacted along with all
the other small communities so they had
not only tourism that was coming in they
also had all these people coming from
all over yet they had people from the
city looking for a more suburban
lifestyle but they also had people from
the rural countryside coming in and
trying to bind land where they could
live close enough to the city to get
work
so it's been a unique privilege to
experience that and and work with the
women
alongside that that's kind of how you
you see me as graduate faculty in
women's studies as well as an
anthropology but also the director of
the Center for Latin American Studies
okay
okay so mmm so interesting that you
dropped banking to pursue anthropology
that's so interesting and hopefully can
inspire other people to make shifts in
their career right yes because look at
what happened is you went on you've
given us this really interesting visual
where you have a city you have Oaxaca
you said eight kilometers away from
Mexico City
no from Oaxaca City from the kapa haka
Sokka City okay so what Hakka is a
smaller maraca city is the capital city
of the state of Oaxaca Oaxaca City is
the capital city of the state of Oaxaca
and then there are smaller cities that
you were sent immediate Sampa is the
community that I work in well started
out so it's office which is eight
kilometers outside of Santa Maria at
Samba at Samba ATZ ATZ om PA what's
something I don't but Santa Maria at
Samba so Santa Maria de SOPA had fifty
two hundred people eight kilometers away
from Oaxaca City and then there was over
the last twenty twenty-five years it's
now a cold getting closer to sixty
thousand people because as the
population has grown of the city of
Oaxaca City and of Mexico in general
people are starting to want to live
further out of the complex metropolis
closer to nature let's say and then they
pick Santa Maria odds odds that's
something that's on par and then also
yeah so the most urban most cities grow
not from internal population it's not
internal population that causes cities
to grow cities grow because people come
in from other places
Economic Opportunity absolutely you know
the companies move in and they hire
people and people move there in order to
be part of it you know I mean across
time cities from their point of origin
you know from the original early cities
they grow not from internal population
growth but from external populations
moving closer to whatever resources that
city has to offer and so you see the
same thing here at simple used to be
this peripheral you know rural community
but it didn't take very long because of
its proximity and then once they once
they put that bridge and that highway in
over the river you know before they were
you know the Knights all the way up
through the 1980s they didn't they
didn't get electricity until the 1970s
so all the way through the 1980s they
were still waiting through a river in
order to cross over to get into the city
so but I'm if they're in the in the
1990s there were many people who'd never
been to the city yeah eight kilometers
away there were many people who had
never been to the city but life has
changed so much it's now just this major
used to be what we would call Perry
urban space it's very much an urban
space now peri-urban peri-urban yeah why
PE RI PE RI peri-urban is roughly 35,000
or less people ya know now it's just
urban do they still farm absolutely do
yeah absolutely it's still very much a
part of their identity so if we
basically took a satellite that is
constantly with the camera that's
constantly scanning the population
increase and the movement of people to
Metropolis is over time we could then
observe like you know click in 1990 and
then drag over to you know 2020 and we
could watch as people that are birthed
in Mexico decide to move to Oaxaca City
and the nearby at SOPA and then you can
you can just literally observe the city
go from 50 to 100 and this is happening
basically across the entire planet with
metropolis because people are moving to
Metropolis
so it's interesting then so maybe one of
the core theses here is that just that
as urbanization has happened that we've
had these smaller peri-urban peri-urban
cities that are that were initially
maybe a little bit more you know five
thousand people what not see themselves
jump up in 25 years two completely
different cultural dynamics due to the
emigration of other people for economic
opportunity absolutely one of the things
to understand is that was prompted by
NAFTA and by reforms to the Mexican
Constitution in 1992 that took effect in
1993 where indigenous lands that were
held in a kind of Hiva system which
basically means that all of their
agricultural lands were held in in
common and so even though you had had
that land in your family for a very long
time you didn't own it so you couldn't
sell it because it belonged to the
community it belonged to our ability to
survive as a community but the lands
that you had would always be yours and
you could send them down to your
children and their children but that was
the problem so you may have started out
with enough land to have fed a large
family but then you have to split it up
with your children in order for them to
have land and for them to have their
families and then they have to split it
up among their children so that land
begins to feed fewer and fewer and fewer
people and you couldn't sell it because
it was communally owned lands and the
community only has so much land to
distribute out right so this is one of
the the reasons that people started
leaving as the land itself couldn't
sustain them but this is also where some
of the original Spanish who who decided
to get on ships and come across the sea
they were second and third sons who
didn't qualify for the inheritance of
their their families properties and
Europe only had so much land right so
you go in search of additional lands in
order for the species to survive in
order for people to figure out how to
survive and go on to the next phase of
their life which is why when they
encounter somebody that seems
be an obstacle to their survival that
oneness becomes a challenge that we
originally started talking about right
so I mean it's the same thing so these
communities so the reforms to article 27
in the Mexican Constitution basically
said that communities could now change
that land designation and turn it into
fee-simple the community had to vote on
it all the landowners under the hilo
system had to vote on it but for many
communities it was like what choice do
we have and many of them liked it some
first started out by saying you know
what this land over here our dry lands
we don't have irrigation let's start
with those lands that sell those lands
and then our children will you know be
able to have an inheritance from the
money that were able to get from them
but they had no control over who got to
buy those lands and so people came in
they split their lands up even more they
started selling more and that's how you
know what was once a protected
indigenous community ends up no longer
being that way and ends up being an
urban center because of its proximity to
work and to to resources that people
need to survive Wow the untold stories
of urbanization right
oh they're told they're told we teach it
in our classrooms all the time right
yeah now you're telling again and and
hopefully reaching even more people
these are really Wow just but we're
wrestling that with that with our
homeless right we only have so much land
in so much space so unless we're willing
to start chopping up all the land that
we own individually and start selling
that off in order for other housing to
be constructed where are we gonna go
there comes a point right well we're
making we're making the exact same kinds
of decisions will we make the right
decisions I don't know what's up with
this whole thing with governments
getting involved with indigenous like it
like they did I mean this is a very
difficult relationship to
you're out how to how to interplay
dynamics of because you have indigenous
from around the world that are now
inside of these you know inside of these
borders of countries that then have
rules and then that then they may find
themselves at just being stewards of a
piece of land over you know hundreds of
years and then all of a sudden that
changes where they have to follow
something else that so that whole thing
is crazy like that they even have to
think about this division of land and
like selling things off because of the
you know urbanization but I want to ask
you another question because you brought
this up and this is something that I
don't want to
must have forget about you specifically
also did women's studies there and you
did you said it was the pot pottery was
this yeah
pottery was done right and you watched
he said four generations of women yes
I'm on my fourth generation of women in
terms of who I'm working with an
understanding other their understanding
themselves and the choices that they
make as women to be able to fulfill
their there are dreams and it's a
ceramic producing community they
produced an amazingly beautiful emerald
green almost the color of your shirt
emerald green ceramic it's what we call
utilitarian ceramic because it is a
ceramic that you cook with so if you go
anywhere in Mexico you will see this
utilitarian ceramic in the back kitchens
it's normally the kind of that rust
color on the inside or it may be green
on the inside too and then this
beautiful green glaze this green glaze
seals it and makes it waterproof it
makes it durable and heat but what makes
it green LED so the ability for these
communities to create a glaze right that
is going to stand up to cooking over a
long period of time means that they need
some kind of fluxing agent with the
color that will allow it to come in
penetrate through the natural clay and
make it impermeable and so it takes a
very high temperature comb
to be able to seal that sufficiently
that you aren't going to have negative
repercussions from lead leaching into
the foods that you're preparing yeah
might have been fine at one time but
then you have deforestation and you have
the cost of lumber going up which means
these communities who are producing a
base utilitarian ceramic can no longer
access the thick heavy wood that would
have allowed for higher temperature
kilns to occur so as the quality of the
wood goes down that means that the
temperature and the kilns goes down
which means they need a more and more of
this flexing agent in order for it to
liquefy and be able to create this glaze
that seals the ceramic so if you look at
lead content from the 1950s 60s you know
you're basically looking at an eighteen
to maybe twenty two percent lead content
in the glaze but they still had kilns
that were probably closer to 800 850
degrees Celsius by the time I'm in there
doing my research in the 1990s and and I
took a team of graduate student
researchers in there and we tested the
cones and we tested but you're looking
at 60 65 percent lead in these glazes
and you're looking at kilns that only
reach four hundred four hundred and
sixty degrees Celsius which means
they're not sealing in that lead in the
way in which they did and so the
community is now suffering from massive
health repercussions from lead poisoning
which is how I ended up getting into
nutrition because once LED is in your
body really there's nothing we can do
about it because your body thinks LED is
calcium so it places lead everywhere it
would have placed calcium and because
it's a metal it bonds with iron which
means all the iron that you're receiving
to prevent anemia is bonding to the lead
right the melenik you'll which your body
thinks is calcium so you're urinating it
out so at the same time your body is
putting lead where calcium oughta go
you're in deficient you're also getting
a hearing deficiency so the health
maladies which you know they're massive
their deafness kidney failure
there's children are being born with
learning disabilities so in testing they
basically say that for every 10
micrograms per deciliter of lead in your
blood you're going to have a loss in
your intelligence quotient of about you
know 6 points well if the average is a
hundred when we tested many of these
children they were between 40 and 50
micrograms per deciliter so 6 times 40
you know that's 24 24 from 175 places
you at that point of mental I don't want
to say disability but but it it
prohibits a kind of learning that we
need so you're running around with
people who can't learn to read that's
the number one thing that we found out
they could do mathematics wonderfully
but we we couldn't teach them to read we
couldn't get them to remember how to
make a signature so everything from
learning disabilities you know into
complete kidney failure deafness it's it
was really tough so since I can't change
your body the only thing I can do is
fight the outcomes of it through
nutrition which means upping your
calcium upping your protein right and
then making sure that I have the other
vitamins in there so that it's
efficiently bonds but it's a fight
inside your body and every body absorbs
differently and then well it's crazy
that that entire economic equation that
happened with the lumber and then making
the actual pottery with the lead and
then having that also have over time
more of the lead that then gets into the
body then causes the ailments due to
again something like an urbanization is
just this is a insane butterfly effect
that's happening and then just this
other point is is it then transitioning
away yeah this isn't like a symptoms are
these issues you're listing and then the
as a solution yet the the main route
though is the actual cooking is there
it's more than just the cooking because
women's identity is ceramic production
it's what gave them political and
economic autonomy yeah it was the reason
for the first time that women became
independent economic earners so now I'm
the one going to the women and saying
your ceramic is harming you and it's
harming your children no no it is not
we've been making this ceramic for you
know hundreds of years kind of thing and
many of the outcomes of lead poisoning
mirror malnutrition anemia right
headaches other bodily issues you know
kidney failure that that all mirrors
malnutrition in many ways so for them it
is a pattern of health malady that has
followed them across time so even though
they're wealthier now and that's a
relative term right
women are politically autonomous which
means that they are empowered inside the
household and it took you know my work
is basically look at how it looked at
how long it took for women to actually
have that autonomy where men respected
them yeah but now you ask women to give
up the very thing that gave them that
empowerment and that defines them as as
viable people that that community is
known for its ceramic if they stop
producing ceramic they're not that
community anymore there's something else
they're an urban anonymous entity so the
way in which their identity is tied to
it the way in which women have to make
decisions about what do I do do I give
up this ability to be autonomous and so
you know the the women that I'm working
with children who didn't have learning
disabilities were invested in and sent
to school children with learnings about
disabilities were taught the ceramic
trade so they were always balancing it
but now you have women here with
university education now you have women
who are doctors women who are
accountants women who are pharmacists
women who are doing all kinds of things
but it took all of that
and all of that sacrifice but it also
took siblings who do have those learning
disabilities because they have to
maintain that identity so when you go
into these spaces you think you're
looking at one thing but you are looking
at the complex way in which we human
beings make sense out of our world and
our traumas and our successes are
intimately linked and tied together so
whether you're thinking about how do I
deal with this particular issue of lead
poisoning or you're thinking about how
do I make decisions about the
incorporation of artificial intelligence
in my life you are looking at these ways
in which we have to think about our
histories about our contemporary moment
and where we stand as a people against
other peoples are we a marginalized
population are we an indigenous
population that has a hard time
accessing anyway what do you want me to
do you want me to give that up when for
the first time I'm being incorporated
into the larger state conversation yeah
those are the kinds of things that we
wrestle with that we try to document
that we try to understand and give that
kind of human reflection on it's not
that simple first thing people always
ask me is well why don't they stop using
it yeah but I just tried to swear I was
just going with the root issue why don't
we go there's identity that's tied to it
because they gained autonomy women gain
autonomy so urbanization actually helped
to bring potentially some of the
autonomy but then also then now it made
it so that again with the complexity of
having the health issues arrived the
giving up of the autonomy is and the
identity how do you sell me out rich how
do you maybe sweat like what's the
what's the next best thing switching to
another sort of safer way to make make
it absolutely that's the next question
that people always ask me but here's the
deal I can make a lead-based ceramic pot
for the kitchen that might cost twenty
five thirty pesos right so it might cost
me a couple bucks US Dollars conversion
but if I have to go to a gas kiln which
is going to give me it's going to allow
me to low
the lead content or use a non lead use a
copper based flexing agent instead I
have to get a kiln
well Kim isn't going to be I'm not gonna
be able to put as many items in that
kiln but the cost of the count is right
around 10,000 us the cost of the kiln
then the cost of the gas to run it which
means that ceramic pot isn't going to
cost you 20 to 30 vessels anymore that
pot is going to cost you 200 to 300
pesos and you're not going to buy a pot
for two or three hundred pesos because
you're a tourist and you don't carry
ceramic back it's heavy so their actual
consumers are some tourists and actually
it's more domestic tourists it's more
people in Mexico who can drive to Oaxaca
by their household ceramic and take it
back then it is you and me coming in and
saying but I'll buy your you're higher
priced ceramic pot because it's still a
good price for me in the US because that
same pot in the US isn't going to cost
two or three hundred pesos it's going to
cost two or three hundred dollars
because it's an indigenous pot from
Oaxaca but they don't ever see that and
they don't have the marketing capacity
to be able to export it Plus this is
potentially happening all around the
world all around the world yes because
cottage craft is is helping small
marginalized populations survive so that
the states don't have to invest in them
well so there's some autonomy that comes
with making this cottage craft yet then
the government's don't need to invest
into they can be like oh you have
economic but now you become part of the
consumerism cycle and then
you joined the economic machinery which
you never actually subscribed to be a
part of in the first place so I go from
looking at gender and how we make
decisions about what elements of our
culture we will continue to perpetuate
across time even as we are addressing
new structures for our children to now
understanding how women were empowered
through the very commodification of
their bodies and their craft
which ended up producing severe health
negative health outcomes which moved me
into nutrition and nutrition
intervention which moved me into
understanding the symbolic significance
of food what if I'm going to do recipe
modification in order to increase your
calcium and increase your your your
protein consumption your iron I need to
understand what textures are appropriate
for you what tastes are appropriate for
you because if I start substituting
things out I'm gonna change that and
some things you're just not going to eat
so you have to balance that so then you
learn you start to learn how women also
identify with the food that they produce
and also how men understand that they're
being cared for based on the quality of
food that is being prepared for them
yeah so if you interrupt that you're not
going to win they're not in it they're
not going to maintain this recipe
intervention this nutrition intervention
that you're hoping will it reimpose
their bodies so you start learning about
food and the symbolic significance of
food and how food is tied to identity
and food is tied to futures and so this
is how as anthropologists I think in
many ways our research just kind of kind
of grows and grows and grows and shifts
and changes and become so many things at
the same time it's really about the same
whoa this yeah again at this macro level
in terms of observing the planet over
time from like a satellite view
urbanizing and then the effects of that
has on indigenous communities the
effects that that has on communities
that are directly outside of urban
metropolis is the way that that kind of
machinery pressures
go into doing things into transitioning
from potentially their
interconnectedness with the ecosystem
that they're a part of to now doing
things like partaking in the economic
machinery to the land that they were on
now having more and more people love
living in those areas the health issue
you're talking about autonomy all these
cost and they're wrong this was nuts
this is so crazy Lee complex and this
has been the main focus for you and the
research was yes and and I follow people
who do choose to migrate so as they've
moved out of Oaxaca and moved into Baja
California and other parts of Mexico I
look at how these Oaxacan communities
reinvent community and maintain their
senses of identity in these other places
all the way in through the US it also
means that I understand the traumas and
the perils that they go through and
because of my work on women's autonomy I
understand domestic violence and
violence against women and children and
some really profound and intimate ways
since I watch it unfold and you know
when you when you when you do gender
research you can't talk to one you can't
you have to be able to incorporate the
multiple genders that exist you have to
be able to hear from men why they do the
things that they do as well as from
women why they do the things that they
do so beginning to understand how
domestic violence is understood and
violence against women and children is
understood how its perpetuated how it's
not a priority for the Mexican state
because it's so culturally bound because
of all of these things this leads me
into expert witness testimony a lot of
times in the asylum courts as women and
children are coming across and saying
you have to save my life you can't send
me back there so there yeah there are
there are really intimate ways in which
as an anthropologist the very intimacy
of living among communities for the
length of time that we do for spending
the time with them and going across time
and understanding how their worlds
collide with with other worlds
understanding the whole global impact
also requires us to be able to say that
out loud to the public and to be able to
stand up and say it's not as simple as
you're trying to make it let me let me
take you on a journey let me take you
all the way back through the history of
these people and what is happening to
them today one of the things I always
try to tell my students you cannot
understand the decisions that somebody's
making today if you don't know their
history exactly that's why you have to
ask questions and learn about people's
history and culture this is the moment
that's why questions are everything the
only quality of your life is that
quality of your questions do you know
how to ask people questions they can
gain give you the understanding of their
history so that you're not just watching
some two-minute mainstream media news
clip about a certain thing but rather
you've actually done the dive into
Oaxaca City and the nearby areas that
then give you the understanding what's
happening you give this profound story
of a human you know experiencing
domestic violence issues that comes and
says please let me save me save me and
that's much different than what media
portrays periods that we've never ever
medias and anything may have before
portrayed stories like this but it's so
extremely rare to see an actual
long-form segment about people like that
that then need to have help away from
domestic abuse and like you said the
close ties that it has where there's not
actually help coming into those areas to
solve things like this because of the
cultural associations and stuff like
that that's it's very value according to
the state how the value decides which
populations are worth their investment
and which ones aren't and and you know
gendered violence is much deeper and
it's much more complex than that because
there are ways in which domestic
violence also communicates out into
larger community based violence and how
that then turns into cartel violence how
it turns into all these kinds of things
that is a whole nother segment that is a
whole conversation all of what you've
just been talking about especially you
know you were mentioning this a little
bit ago
you said immigration expert witness
testimony child detention domestic
violence the complexity of all of these
things trans transnational migrant youth
of the trauma that comes with that
ethnic marginalization general all of
this this is a great part to to to
explore with you and much more and maybe
more on the answers to exploring on
hitting back and forth around some of
those initial questions that we were
talking about as well this has been
super enlightening I want to ask you
just one last thought because what is
the most beautiful about this reality
about this reality what is most
beautiful yeah Wow
there's so much beauty actually there's
so much trauma but there's so much
beauty and I think the greatest beauty
is looking into the eyes of a stranger
and receiving a smile that goes back to
yeah well one I love that looking at
another and seeing yourself and then
never inflicting seeing them or seeing
them seeing them not yourself you see
them and you smile which is all us you
see them which is us and you never
commit oh but it's never just me yeah
yeah we're gonna thank you again so much
for coming on the program you're welcome
Wow
then congrats again on the role thank
you you're a triple-a in the Association
is really really important to me I have
been involved with Association
leadership since I was a graduate
student yep yep all four years thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments blowing the
episode let us know sure thinking check
out the links in the bio below to
Ramona's work also check out the links
in the bio blow to the American
Anthropological Association check them
on support them please yes please and
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
organizations a community
around the world that you believe and
support them and help them flourish to
find all of the links below to our show
as a PayPal patreon cryptocurrency you
can design cool merch and get paid all
those links in the bio below and go and
build the future everyone and if s your
dreams into the world build a just
social fabric we love you very much see
you soon
[Music]
you
[Music]
but not everyone's a good storyteller
not everyone's a good synthesizer and
not everyone really truly cares that the
depth of their heart and those are those
are probably the big differences so
you